- Willkommen zurück bei „Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation." Mein Name ist John Watrous, und ich bin der Technical Director
für IBM Quantum Education.
Dies ist die fünfte Lektion der Serie und die erste Lektion in
der zweiten Einheit der Serie, die sich mit Quantenalgorithmen befasst.
In dieser Einheit werden wir
rechnerische Vorteile von Quanteninformation untersuchen, das heißt, wir schauen uns an,
was wir tun können
mit Quantencomputern und welche Vorteile Quantencomputer potenziell gegenüber
klassischen Computern haben könnten.
Wir werden uns darauf konzentrieren, was wir mit einem einzelnen Quantencomputer tun können, im Gegensatz zu einer verteilten
Umgebung, zum Beispiel,
wo mehrere Quantencomputer über eine Art Netzwerk interagieren.
Es gibt tatsächlich Quantenvorteile in verteilten Umgebungen, wo Kommunikation und
Kryptographie eine Rolle spielen,
aber darüber werden wir
in dieser Einheit nicht sprechen.
Diese Einheit handelt von Quantenalgorithmen, die auf einzelnen Quantencomputern laufen.
Fangen wir mit einer naheliegenden Frage an. Welche Vorteile könnte ein Quantencomputer
potenziell bieten?
Der wichtigste ist, dass Quantencomputer möglicherweise schnellere Lösungen für einige Rechenprobleme liefern könnten.
Zeit ist kostbar, und obwohl die Computer, die wir
täglich nutzen, ziemlich schnell sind, sind sie immer noch viel zu langsam,
um bestimmte Rechenprobleme zu lösen, einfach wegen der inhärenten
rechnerischen Schwierigkeit dieser Probleme.
Dieses Potenzial, dass Quantencomputer uns ermöglichen könnten, Probleme zu lösen, für die klassische Computer
zu langsam sind,
ist wirklich das, was
die Forschung zu Quantenalgorithmen in den letzten Jahrzehnten angetrieben hat.
Es gibt andere rechnerische
Ressourcen außer der Zeit, die berücksichtigt werden können, wie die Menge an Computerspeicher, die für Berechnungen benötigt wird,
aber Quantencomputer können
in Bezug auf Speicher nicht allzu viel einsparen, wie sich herausstellt, und klassischer Computerspeicher
ist ziemlich günstig
besonders im Vergleich zu Quantenspeicher. Es gibt also
kaum Hoffnung in dieser Richtung.
Wir könnten auch an andere Ressourcen denken, wie die Menge an Energie,
die für Berechnungen benötigt wird, aber du brauchst eigentlich
gar nicht viel Energie
um klassisch zu rechnen, besonders wenn du bereit bist,
die Dinge zu verlangsamen.
Es ist also wirklich die Zeit,
die für Berechnungen benötigt wird, das ist unser Hauptfokus.
Hier ist eine Übersicht für die Lektion, die sich mit einem spezifischen
Berechnungsmodell befasst, bekannt als das Query-Modell.
Du kannst dir dieses Modell vorstellen wie eine Petrischale für die Entwicklung algorithmischer Ideen, sowohl quantenmäßiger als auch klassischer.
Es ist nicht als praktisches Modell gedacht, das die Art von
Rechenproblemen beschreibt, die wir im echten Leben begegnen.
Wir werden das Query-Modell in späteren Lektionen dieser Einheit verlassen und uns stattdessen auf Modelle konzentrieren, die durch praktischere
Vorstellungen von Berechnung motiviert sind,
aber das Query-Modell ist ein
sehr guter Ausgangspunkt.
Es ist ein einfaches Modell, das es uns ermöglicht, das
Potenzial von Quantencomputern zu erkunden, ohne dass viele technische
Details im Weg stehen,
und es erlaubt uns auch, einige der
wirklich wichtigen Ideen hinter Quantencomputing und dessen Funktionsweise zu isolieren.
Quantencomputing hat sich tatsächlich zuerst innerhalb dieses Modells entwickelt, und die Ideen, die
darin entwickelt wurden, haben sehr direkt
wichtige Quantenalgorithmen inspiriert,
wie Shors Algorithmus zur Faktorisierung.
Im ersten Abschnitt der Lektion schauen wir uns genau an, was das Query-Modell der Berechnung ist,
und im zweiten, dritten
und vierten Abschnitt werden wir drei
Quanten-Query-Algorithmen besprechen, nämlich Deutschs Algorithmus,
den Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus,
und Simons Algorithmus, die zunehmend
beeindruckende Vorteile zeigen
von Quantencomputern
gegenüber klassischen Computern innerhalb des Query-Modells der Berechnung.
Um das Query-Modell der Berechnung zu erklären, beginnen wir zuerst mit einer eher standardmäßigen
Abstraktion von Berechnung.
Hier ist ein Bild, das
eine Berechnung in sehr einfachen und grundlegenden Begriffen darstellt.
Wir haben eine Eingabe, die normalerweise die
Form eines Binärstrings annimmt, obwohl wir andere
Symbole verwenden könnten, wenn wir wollten.
Die Eingabe wird der Berechnung bereitgestellt, die durch ein blaues
Rechteck in diesem Bild dargestellt wird,
und das Ergebnis der Berechnung ist, dass eine Ausgabe produziert wird, und das ist wieder meistens
ein Binärstring.
Natürlich sagt dieses Bild
überhaupt nichts darüber aus, wie die Berechnung selbst funktioniert.
Wir können verschiedene
spezifische Berechnungsmodelle dafür formulieren, wie Turing-Maschinen
und Boolesche circuit,
oder quantum circuits, wenn wir über
Quantenberechnung nachdenken.
Es stimmt, dass dieses Bild
nicht die Tatsache darstellt, dass viele der
Computer, die wir täglich verwenden, kontinuierlich
Eingaben empfangen und Ausgaben produzieren,
und im Wesentlichen mit uns und mit anderen Computern über
das Internet interagieren, zum Beispiel.
Aber wir versuchen nicht,
diese Interaktionen hier darzustellen.
Hier geht es darum,
isolierte Rechenaufgaben zu modellieren.
Zum Beispiel könnte die Eingabe die
binäre Kodierung einer Zahl oder eine Darstellung einer Matrix sein
oder eine Beschreibung eines Moleküls oder wirklich irgendetwas anderes, das wir im Sinn haben, und es gibt eine Rechenaufgabe
an dieser Eingabe allein durchgeführt wird.
Der entscheidende Punkt hier ist,
dass die gesamte Eingabe der Berechnung bereitgestellt wird und nichts über die
Eingabe vor ihr verborgen ist.
Das Abfragemodell der
Berechnung funktioniert anders.
Im Abfragemodell wird die Eingabe
in Form einer Funktion bereitgestellt, auf die die Berechnung
durch Abfragen zugreifen kann,
oder anders gesagt, indem die Funktion
mit verschiedenen Eingaben ausgewertet wird.
Hier siehst du das
in Form eines Bildes dargestellt.
Ähnlich wie zuvor wird die Berechnung durch
ein blaues Rechteck dargestellt, aber anstatt eine Eingabe direkt zu erhalten,
in Form einer Zeichenkette
aus Bits beispielsweise, greift sie auf die Eingabe zu, indem sie effektiv Fragen stellt
und Antworten empfängt.
Manchmal verwenden wir die Begriffe
Orakel und Black Box, um den Mechanismus zu bezeichnen,
der die Eingabe bereitstellt.
In der Komplexitätstheorie gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen
einem Orakel und einer Black Box, aber das ist für die Zwecke dieser Diskussion überhaupt nicht relevant.
Jedenfalls sollen diese Begriffe
die Grundidee vermitteln.
Im antiken Griechenland konntest du
zu einem Orakel gehen, wie dem Orakel von Delphi,
und eine wichtige Frage stellen,
und das Orakel würde genau diese
Frage beantworten, aber es würde dir sicher nicht alles erzählen, was es wusste.
In ähnlicher Weise denken wir,
wenn wir an eine Black Box denken, an eine Art
Prozess oder System,
bei dem wir wählen können, was hineingeht, und wir sehen können, was herauskommt, aber wir haben kein Verständnis
von seiner inneren Funktionsweise.
Und das ist hier der Fall. Die Eingabe für das Problem
hat die Form einer Funktion, und alles, was wir tun können, ist,
diese Funktion auszuwerten,
aber ansonsten haben wir
keinerlei Wissen oder Verständnis davon, wie sie funktioniert.
Im Verlauf der Lektion
reservieren wir den Buchstaben f für die Funktion, die
die Eingabe repräsentiert, und wir treffen die Annahme,
dass sie immer die
Form hat, die du hier siehst.
Sigma bezeichnet das binäre Alphabet, also ist f eine Funktion von Zeichenketten
aus Bits zu Zeichenketten aus Bits,
und genauer gesagt nehmen wir an,
dass die Eingabe für f eine Zeichenkette aus Bits der Länge n ist, und die Ausgabe eine Zeichenkette
aus Bits der Länge m,
wobei n und m positive ganze Zahlen sind.
Für verschiedene Probleme werden wir
Einschränkungen für n und m haben, aber in allen Fällen wird die Eingabefunktion
eine solche Form annehmen.
Wenn wir sagen, dass eine
Berechnung eine Abfrage macht, meinen wir damit, dass die
Funktion f einmal ausgewertet wird,
das heißt, eine bestimmte Zeichenkette x der Länge N wird von der Berechnung ausgewählt, und die Zeichenkette f von x wird
ihr dann zur Verfügung gestellt
durch das Orakel oder die Black Box. Und schließlich ist die sehr einfache Art und Weise, wie wir die Rechenkosten messen werden,
die eines Abfragealgorithmus darin, zu zählen, wie viele Abfragen er benötigt.
Also, obwohl es stimmt, dass
wir wirklich am meisten daran interessiert sind, wie lange Berechnungen dauern, wenn wir das Abfragemodell untersuchen,
halten wir die Dinge im Allgemeinen
einfach und zählen nur Abfragen, und das werden wir in dieser Lektion tun.
Nun lass uns einen Blick auf einige
Beispiele für Abfrageprobleme werfen, also Berechnungsprobleme
im Abfragemodell,
und hier werde ich übrigens nur
die Probleme selbst beschreiben, und an diesem Punkt werde ich nichts
darüber sagen, wie man sie löst.
Das erste Problem ist das ODER-Problem.
In diesem Fall ist die Eingabe eine Funktion
von n Bits zu nur 1 Bit, also ist m für dieses Problem gleich 1,
und die erforderliche Ausgabe für
das Problem ist entweder 1 oder 0.
Wenn es eine n-Bits-Zeichenkette x gibt, für die f von x gleich 1 ist, dann ist die richtige Antwort 1,
und andernfalls, wenn f von x
für jede Zeichenkette x immer 0 ist, dann ist die richtige Antwort 0.
Wenn wir also die Funktion f so betrachten, dass sie uns zufälligen
Zugriff auf zwei hoch n Bits bietet, einen für jede n-Bit-Zeichenkette x,
dann fragt sie nach
dem ODER dieser Bits, und deshalb heißt es das ODER-Problem.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist das Paritätsproblem, das dem ODER-Problem ähnlich ist, außer dass es nach der Parität fragt,
oder mit anderen Worten, dem exklusiven ODER aller einstelligen
Ausgabewerte der Funktion.
Eine andere Art, das zu sagen, ist,
dass die richtige Antwort 0 ist, wenn die Anzahl der n-Bit-Zeichenketten x, für die f von x gleich 1 ist, gerade ist,
und die richtige Antwort
1 ist, wenn diese Zahl ungerade ist.
Ein Beispiel für ein Problem, bei dem m nicht notwendigerweise gleich 1 ist, ist das Minimumproblem.
Hier hat die Funktion f die übliche Form, und es gibt keine Einschränkungen für n und m,
und die richtige Antwort ist der Ausgabewert
der Funktion, der in der lexikografischen
oder Wörterbuchreihenfolge
von Binärzeichenketten zuerst kommt. Alternativ, wenn du dir
Zeichenketten der Länge m als nicht-negative
ganze Zahlen in binärer Notation vorstellen möchtest,
dann ist die richtige Antwort
der kleinstmögliche oder minimale Wert, der
aus dieser Funktion herauskommt.
Manchmal betrachten wir auch Abfrageprobleme, bei denen wir ein Versprechen
auf die Eingabefunktion haben, oder mit anderen Worten, eine
Art Garantie darauf,
und wir uns keine Gedanken über Funktionen machen, die dieses Versprechen nicht erfüllen.
Funktionen, die das Versprechen nicht erfüllen, gelten als „don't care"-Eingaben.
Und wir sind einfach nicht dafür verantwortlich, was bei diesen Eingaben passiert.
Hier ist ein Beispiel für ein Abfrageproblem mit einem Versprechen, das als „Unique Search" bezeichnet wird.
Es ist mit dem OR-Problem
verwandt, aber es ist anders.
Die Eingabefunktion hat dieselbe
Form wie beim OR-Problem: Sie bildet
n-Bit-Zeichenketten auf Bits ab.
Diesmal wird versprochen, dass
es genau eine Zeichenkette Z gibt, die dazu führt, dass f zu 1 ausgewertet wird,
wobei f von x gleich 0
für jede Zeichenkette x außer z ist, und die korrekte Ausgabe
ist diese eindeutige Zeichenkette z.
Natürlich gibt es
Wahlmöglichkeiten für die Funktion f, die diese Bedingung nicht erfüllen, aber wir stellen keinerlei Anforderungen
an Algorithmen für dieses Problem, wenn ihnen solche
Funktionen als Eingabe gegeben werden.
Wir kümmern uns nur um die Funktionen, die das Versprechen tatsächlich erfüllen.
Nun, alle vier der
Probleme, die ich gerade erwähnt habe, sind ziemlich natürliche Probleme – das heißt, sie sind leicht zu erklären,
und es ist leicht, sich Situationen vorzustellen, in denen die Notwendigkeit entsteht, sie zu lösen, aber manche Abfrageprobleme
sind überhaupt nicht so.
Tatsächlich betrachten wir manchmal hochgradig
konstruierte Abfrageprobleme, bei denen es schwer vorstellbar ist, dass sie jemand
jemals wirklich lösen wollen würde.
Simons Problem, das wir
später in der Lektion sehen werden, fällt ein bisschen in diese Kategorie, aber es gibt noch andere,
die in gewisser Hinsicht noch weit schlimmer sind, die aber dennoch tatsächlich ziemlich wichtig für das Studium des Abfragemodells sind.
Wir studieren diese Probleme nicht, weil wir sie unbedingt
in der Praxis lösen wollen.
Du kannst es so verstehen, dass wir nach
Extremen verschiedener Art suchen,
insbesondere wenn wir innerhalb
dieser Petrischale eines Modells arbeiten – ein natürlicher Weg, um
quantenalgorithmische Ideen zu erkunden,
besteht darin, hochgradig konstruierte Probleme zu formulieren, bei denen wir die
Stärke von Quantencomputern am besten ausnutzen können.
Und das kann tatsächlich
sehr viel Licht darauf werfen, wie Quantencomputer
in praktischeren Umgebungen nützlich sein könnten.
Wir können den Begriff
einer Abfrage je nach verwendetem Berechnungsmodell
auf verschiedene Weisen formalisieren.
Zum Beispiel gibt es im Turing-
Maschinenmodell der Berechnung, über das wir nicht gesprochen haben und das wir in dieser Reihe nicht vertiefen werden,
eine bestimmte Möglichkeit,
den Begriff einer Abfrage zu formalisieren, die für dieses Modell sinnvoll ist.
Für circuit-Modelle definieren wir spezielle Typen von
gates, sogenannte Query-gates, und so werden Abfragen
formal dargestellt.
Für Boolesche circuits gibt es eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit, dies zu tun, nämlich sich einfach vorzustellen,
dass wir Query-gates haben,
die die Eingabefunktion direkt auswerten, wie du hier auf dem Bildschirm sehen kannst.
Die Idee ist, dass wir
diese Query-gates verwenden können, um circuits zu bauen, die das jeweilige
Problem lösen,
und um korrekt zu funktionieren, müssen die circuits die richtige Antwort liefern, welche Eingabefunktion f auch immer gegeben wird,
unter der Annahme, dass sie im Fall eines Promise-Problems das Versprechen erfüllt.
Hier ist ein einfaches Beispiel
für einen Booleschen circuit, der das Paritätsproblem
löst, wenn n gleich 1 ist,
also ist die Eingabefunktion f in diesem Fall
von 1 Bit auf 1 Bit.
Was dieser circuit tut, ist die Funktion
f auf den Eingaben 0 und 1 mithilfe dieser zwei Query-gates auszuwerten.
Dann steckt er die zwei Ausgabewerte, die er
von den Query-gates erhält, in den Booleschen circuit aus Lektion drei, der das XOR berechnet,
was dasselbe ist wie die Parität.
Um es klar zu sagen: Diese zwei
Eingabewerte hier sind keine Eingaben in das Problem,
also das Paritätsproblem,
wenn wir mit dem Abfragemodell arbeiten – die Eingabe in das Problem
ist die Funktion f, und du solltest dir diese
zwei Eingaben in den circuit
als fest kodierte
Werte vorstellen, die sich nie ändern – sie sind im Wesentlichen Teil des Algorithmus.
Wir wollen das XOR von f 0 und f 1 berechnen, also initialisieren wir diese
zwei Leitungen auf diese Weise,
damit es funktioniert. Wir haben hier zwei Query-gates
verwendet, dieses und dieses,
und der Algorithmus, der durch
diesen Booleschen circuit dargestellt wird, macht zwei Abfragen – und wenn wir das
Paritätsproblem kurz betrachten,
für Funktionen von einem Bit auf ein Bit, sehen wir, dass es absolut notwendig ist, dass jeder Boolesche circuit,
der dieses Problem löst,
mindestens zwei Abfragen macht.
Wenn du nur eine Abfrage machst, sodass du nur einen
Ausgabewert der Funktion f kennst und nicht den anderen, hast du eigentlich überhaupt keine
Information
über die Parität, weil der andere Ausgabewert
genauso gut 0 oder 1 sein könnte, was zu einer der zwei möglichen Lösungen
des Problems führt. Was also die Anzahl
der Abfragen betrifft, ist dieser Boolesche circuit so gut wie es nur geht,
für das Paritätsproblem
wenn n gleich 1 ist.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Punkt über Query-gates, der es wert ist, erwähnt zu werden, bevor wir weitermachen: Wenn wir Query-Algorithmen entwerfen und analysieren,
machen wir uns überhaupt keine Gedanken darüber, wie
Query-gates implementiert werden.
Es wird davon ausgegangen, dass uns diese
query gates gegeben werden, und die Schwierigkeit, sie zu bauen,
ist nicht unser Problem.
Du kannst dir die
query gates selbst als Eingabe vorstellen, wenn du möchtest, und es ist nicht unsere Aufgabe, die Eingabe zu erstellen – wir versuchen nur,
ein bestimmtes Problem zu lösen
angesichts der Eingabe. Natürlich gibt es, wenn f eine Funktion
von einem Bit zu einem Bit ist, nur vier mögliche Varianten,
und es wäre einfach genug,
jede davon zu implementieren, aber im Allgemeinen gilt für Funktionen
mit vielen Eingabe-Bits,
dass es extrem schwierig sein kann, query gates
für diese Funktionen zu implementieren.
Um das klarzustellen: Das bedeutet nicht,
dass die Frage, wie query gates implementiert werden,
unwichtig ist, sondern nur, dass sie nicht als Teil
der Kosten eines
Query-Algorithmus betrachtet wird.
Das ist konsistent mit der Idee, dass es hier nicht wirklich
um praktisches Rechnen oder das tatsächliche Bauen von circuits geht,
sondern darum, innerhalb
eines theoretischen Rahmens zu arbeiten, der uns interessante
Dinge über Berechnung verrät.
Dazu werden wir noch mehr sagen, wenn wir den Sprung von diesem Modell zu einem eher standardmäßigen Berechnungsmodell machen – das ist hauptsächlich das Thema der nächsten Lektion,
Lektion 6.
Nun wenden wir uns
den quantum circuits zu.
Bei quantum circuits werden wir die
Definition der query gates ändern, um sie unitär zu machen.
Wir wollen in der Lage sein,
Abfragen innerhalb von quantum circuits zu machen, damit sie
linear auf Quantenzustände wirken
und wir Abfragen effektiv
in Superposition durchführen können.
Es mag wirken, als würden wir
die Ziele verschieben, sozusagen, indem wir ändern, was wir unter einer Abfrage verstehen, verglichen mit dem, was wir gerade
bei Boolean circuits gesehen haben,
aber dafür gibt es eine Begründung, die wir in der nächsten Lektion
ausführlicher besprechen werden.
Fürs Erste ist es nur eine Definition.
Konkret lautet
die Definition wie folgt: Gegeben eine Funktion f
in derselben Form wie zuvor,
d. h. sie bildet n-Bit-Strings
auf m-Bit-Strings ab, wirkt das query gate Uf auf n + m qubits
und ist durch die
hier beschriebene Wirkung auf Standardbasis-Zustände definiert.
Gleich sehen wir eine Abbildung,
die diese Definition darstellt, aber zuerst möchte ich die Notation
erklären, die hier verwendet wird,
nämlich: Immer wenn wir
das Symbol für XOR als Operation zwischen zwei
gleichlangen Strings verwenden,
meinen wir das
bitweise exklusive ODER, und hier siehst du ein Beispiel.
In der Definition gilt, dass sowohl y als auch f von
x Strings der Länge m sind, also steht dieser String hier
für den String, den wir erhalten,
wenn wir diese beiden Strings
bitweise XOR-verknüpfen, und hier ist das Diagramm,
das erklärt, wie diese gates funktionieren.
Die oberen n qubits entsprechen
dem Argument der Funktion.
Wenn sie in einem
Standardbasis-Zustand beginnen – ket x in diesem Diagramm –, geht dieser Standardbasis-Zustand
unverändert hindurch
und wird als Teil der Ausgabe wiedergegeben.
Die unteren m qubits entsprechen der Ausgabe
der Funktion f, und wenn sie in
einem beliebigen Standardbasis-Zustand beginnen,
ket y in diesem Diagramm, passiert Folgendes: Die
Ausgabe der Funktion f von x wird auf den String y XOR-verknüpft.
Das ist es, was für
Standardbasis-Zustände passiert, und wenn wir wissen möchten,
was im Allgemeinen für andere Quantenzustände passiert, nutzen wir
die Linearität, wie wir es immer tun.
Ein Grund, query gates so zu definieren, dass wir die Eingabe spiegeln und das bitweise XOR für die Ausgabe verwenden,
ist, dass diese gates für jede Wahl der Funktion f immer unitär sind.
Dies ist tatsächlich eine
deterministische Operation.
Und wenn wir sie für eine beliebige Wahl einer Funktion F als Matrix ausdrücken würden, erhielten wir eine Permutationsmatrix,
also eine mit einer einzelnen Eins in jeder Zeile und jeder Spalte, und allen anderen Einträgen gleich 0.
Und Permutationsmatrizen
sind immer unitär.
Tatsächlich gilt für diese Operation, dass sie ihre eigene Inverse ist, also gilt: Uf dagger gleich Uf.
Wenn wir mit diesen
gates nur f von x für einen bestimmten String x auswerten wollen, ist das einfach,
wir können y einfach auf
den Alles-Null-String setzen. Wenn wir also das bitweise exklusive ODER mit y berechnen, erhalten wir einfach f von x.
Hier siehst du übrigens die Notation, die verwendet wird, um den Alles-Null-String zu bezeichnen.
Es sieht aus wie 0 hoch M, aber das ist nicht die Bedeutung.
Es bedeutet den String aus Nullen
mit der Länge M.
Wenn wir über
Strings statt über Zahlen sprechen, bedeuten Exponenten typischerweise, dass wir diesen String
eine bestimmte Anzahl von Malen wiederholen,
also ist das 0, m-mal wiederholt.
Es ist einfach eine praktische und präzise Weise, diesen String zu beschreiben.
Noch einmal: Wenn wir
mit dem Query-Modell arbeiten, machen wir uns keine Sorgen darüber,
wie diese query gates implementiert werden.
Das ist dasselbe Problem,
das wir mit query gates für Boolean circuits hatten.
Es ist nicht unsere Aufgabe, die Eingabe vorzubereiten – wir erhalten die Eingabe in
Form dieser Query-gates.
Ich möchte jedoch darauf hinweisen, dass es, wenn wir wissen, wie man
die Funktion f mithilfe eines Boolean circuit implementiert, möglich ist, diese Implementierung
ziemlich direkt in eine quantum
circuit-Implementierung von Uf zu übersetzen, und wir werden in der nächsten Lektion genau sehen,
wie das funktioniert.
Nebenbei bemerkt ist es recht einfach, einen Boolean circuit zu erstellen,
der so funktioniert, indem man ein einziges klassisches
Query-gate für die Funktion f verwendet,
aber das ist etwas ganz anderes, als eine quantum
circuit-Implementierung dieses unitären gate zu haben.
Der Punkt ist jedoch, dass
für klassische Query-Algorithmen ein Query-gate, das so funktioniert, tatsächlich äquivalent ist
zu einem gewöhnlichen
klassischen Query-gate für f, in dem Sinne, dass jedes der beiden mithilfe des anderen implementiert werden kann.
In diesem Abschnitt der Lektion besprechen wir Deutschs Algorithmus, der ein sehr einfacher
quantenbasierter Query-Algorithmus ist, aber wirklich ein Juwel ist.
Dieser Algorithmus stammt aus einem Papier von 1985, das von David Deutsch verfasst wurde, der einer der allerersten Menschen war, der an den theoretischen
Grundlagen des Quantencomputings gearbeitet hat.
Der Algorithmus selbst macht einen sehr kleinen Teil
von Deutschs Papier von 1985 aus, und tatsächlich
ist der Algorithmus, den wir heute
Deutschs Algorithmus nennen, eigentlich eine verbesserte Version des Algorithmus, den Deutsch beschrieben hat.
Er bietet ein sehr bescheidenes Beispiel dafür, wie Quantencomputer
rechnerische Vorteile bieten können, aber man muss irgendwo anfangen,
und es war wirklich ein wichtiger Funke, der die Dinge in Gang gebracht hat.
Deutschs Algorithmus löst ein Query-Problem, das im Kontext des Quantencomputings oft als Deutschs Problem bezeichnet wird,
aber es ist tatsächlich kein anderes
als das Paritätsproblem für Funktionen von einem Bit zu einem Bit, über das wir bereits gesprochen haben.
Wie wir bereits gesehen haben, gibt es vier Funktionen
von einem Bit zu einem Bit, und sie werden hier auf dem Bildschirm durch ihre Wertetabellen beschrieben.
Die erste und die letzte dieser
Funktionen sind konstant, während die mittleren beiden in dem Sinne ausgewogen sind, dass die beiden
möglichen Ausgabewerte
gleich oft vorkommen.
Bei den zwei konstanten Funktionen
sehen wir, dass die Parität, also das eXklusive ODER der beiden Ausgaben, 0 ist,
und bei den zwei ausgewogenen Funktionen ist die Parität der Ausgaben 1.
Eine äquivalente Weise, das
Paritätsproblem in diesem speziellen Fall zu beschreiben, wo die Funktion f
ein einzelnes Bit als Eingabe nimmt,
oder mit anderen Worten, Deutschs Problem, ist wie du es hier siehst.
Die Eingabe ist eine Funktion f
von einem Bit zu einem Bit, und die Ausgabe ist 0, wenn f konstant ist,
und 1, wenn f ausgewogen ist.
Wie ich bereits angedeutet habe, muss jeder klassische Query-Algorithmus,
der dieses Problem löst, mindestens zwei Abfragen an f stellen.
Wenn du nur einen der
beiden Ausgabewerte von f kennst, hast du immer noch überhaupt keine Information über die Parität der beiden Ausgaben.
Und das gilt übrigens auch
für klassische Algorithmen, die Zufälligkeit nutzen.
Zufälligkeit kann manchmal sehr nützlich sein, um Query-Probleme zu lösen, und wir werden später in der Lektion ein Beispiel sehen,
aber Zufälligkeit hilft hier nicht.
Unser Algorithmus von vorhin ist also optimal unter den klassischen Query-Algorithmen
für Deutschs Problem.
Jetzt werfen wir einen Blick
auf Deutschs Algorithmus, der ein quantenbasierter Query-Algorithmus ist, der Deutschs
Problem mit einer einzigen Abfrage löst.
Und hier ist der Algorithmus
als quantum circuit beschrieben.
Wir haben zwei qubits,
die so initialisiert sind, wie du es hier siehst, wobei das obere auf ket 0 und das untere auf ket 1 initialisiert ist,
und wir werden gleich sehen, warum wir diese qubits so initialisieren.
Wir führen Hadamard
gates auf den beiden qubits aus, speisen sie in das Query-gate ein und führen dann ein weiteres Hadamard
gate auf dem oberen qubit aus,
und messen es dann. Und die Behauptung ist, dass
das Messergebnis uns mit Sicherheit die
richtige Antwort auf das Problem liefert.
Lass uns also den
circuit Schritt für Schritt analysieren, um genau zu sehen, wie er funktioniert.
Der Zustand der beiden qubits nach der ersten Schicht von Hadamard gates ist das Tensorprodukt des
Minus- und Plus-Zustands.
Das Hadamard oben bildet
den 0-Zustand auf einen Plus-Zustand ab, und das Hadamard unten bildet den 1-Zustand auf einen Minus-Zustand ab.
Das obere qubit ist rechts, und das untere qubit ist links, also ist das der Zustand, den wir erhalten.
Es ist sehr wichtig, dass das untere qubit in einem Minus-Zustand ist – das würde übrigens nicht funktionieren, wenn wir
das untere qubit
auf einen 0-Zustand statt auf einen 1-Zustand initialisieren.
Wir werden diesen Zustand
halb erweitern, wie du es hier siehst.
Der Grund dafür ist
an diesem Punkt noch nicht klar, aber es wird gleich
praktisch sein.
Als nächstes wollen wir uns überlegen,
wie der Zustand der beiden qubits nach Ausführung des Query-gate aussieht.
Die Funktionsweise des Query-gate
ist, dass es F auf dem Standardbasiszustand
des oberen qubit berechnet und den Wert
mit XOR auf das untere qubit überträgt,
und hier können wir das
Ergebnis davon sehen.
Beim ersten Term ist der Standardbasiszustand
des oberen qubit 0, sodass f von null mit XOR
auf das untere qubit übertragen wird,
und das funktioniert durch Linearität. Und es ist ähnlich beim zweiten Term, außer dass der Standardbasiszustand
für das obere qubit ist 1, also XORen wir f von 1 auf das untere qubit.
Und an diesem Punkt können wir
diesen Ausdruck vereinfachen, indem wir die Formel beobachten,
die du hier unten siehst, welche gilt, wenn a entweder 0 oder 1 ist.
Und wir können das einfach für diese beiden Werte separat überprüfen.
Wenn a gleich 0 ist, dann
bewirkt das XORen mit a nichts, und negativ 1 hoch 0 ist 1,
also sind die beiden Seiten gleich. Und wenn a gleich 1 ist, erhalten wir ket 1 minus ket
0, wenn wir das XOR bilden,
was negativ 1
mal ket 0 minus ket 1 ist.
Und wenn wir diese Formel
verwenden, um unseren Zustand zu vereinfachen, wobei wir a gleich
f von 0 auf der linken Seite und a gleich f von 1 auf der rechten Seite setzen,
erhalten wir den Ausdruck,
den du hier siehst.
Wenn wir also die beiden
Quantenzustandsvektoren π1 und π2 vergleichen, sehen wir, dass das, was das Uf gate tut,
im Wesentlichen darin besteht,
einen der beiden Werte, f von 0 oder f von 1, in den
Exponenten von negativ 1 zu setzen,
oder mit anderen Worten, in
die Phase jedes Terms.
Das ist der Grund dafür,
das untere qubit auf 1 zu initialisieren und ein Hadamard gate darauf anzuwenden, um den Minus-Zustand zu erzeugen,
was dies ermöglicht.
Es heißt das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen, und wir werden in ein paar Momenten darauf zurückkommen, um es noch einmal zu betrachten.
Es ist ziemlich wichtig, und wir werden es noch einige
Male in der Lektion sehen, sowie in späteren Lektionen.
Wir können nun vereinfachen, indem wir
den Minus-Zustand wieder nach außen ziehen, um den Ausdruck
zu erhalten, den du hier siehst.
Nebenbei bemerkt, ist es irgendwie
interessant zu bemerken, dass hier tatsächlich
keine Verschränkung vorhanden ist.
Beide dieser Zustände sind Produktzustände. Also, obwohl Verschränkung
extrem interessant ist,
spielt sie in diesem
speziellen Algorithmus überhaupt keine Rolle.
Lass uns das ein bisschen aufräumen, damit wir etwas mehr Platz haben.
Was wir nun tun können, ist,
einen Faktor von negativ 1 hoch f von null nach außen zu ziehen
um den Ausdruck des
Zustands zu erhalten, den du hier siehst.
Du wirst bemerken, dass wir hier das eXklusive ODER von f 0 und f 1 im Exponenten von negativ 1 haben.
Wir könnten erwarten, dass das
f von 1 minus f von 0 ist, weil wir den Faktor von negativ 1 hoch f von 0 herausziehen,
aber wir erhalten denselben
Wert, wenn wir das XOR nehmen, weil das Bits sind, und das Einzige, was zählt, wenn wir eine ganze Zahl im
Exponenten von negativ 1 haben,
ist, ob diese ganze Zahl gerade oder ungerade ist.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, diesen
Zustand auszudrücken, ist wie wir es hier haben, wo wir nur die
beiden möglichen Fälle für das XOR betrachten.
und das ist eine praktische
Möglichkeit, den Zustand auszudrücken, wenn wir die Wirkung
des letzten Hadamard gates zusammen mit der Messung betrachten.
Wenn wir das letzte
Hadamard gate auf das obere qubit anwenden, wird der Plus-Zustand
in einen 0-Zustand umgewandelt
und der Minus-Zustand wird
in einen 1-Zustand umgewandelt, was wir
kompakter so schreiben können.
Und schließlich, wenn die
Messung durchgeführt wird, ist das Ergebnis, das wir erhalten,
daher das XOR von f 0 und f 1,
was der Wert ist, den wir suchen, und so funktioniert der Algorithmus von Deutsch.
Es ist ziemlich einfach, und wenn wir uns fragen, was
es ist, das es zum Funktionieren bringt, und es uns ermöglicht, die
Parität zweier Bits zu berechnen
mit einer einzigen Abfrage statt zwei, ist eine vernünftige Antwort,
dass es Interferenz ist.
Wir berechnen effektiv
f von 0 und f von 1 gleichzeitig, weil wir zuerst das
Hadamard gate angewendet haben
auf das obere qubit, um die Eingabe in f in
eine Superposition von 0 und 1 zu versetzen.
Und mittels des Phase-Kickbacks zusammen mit dem letzten Hadamard gate erzeugen wir im Wesentlichen konstruktive Interferenz
für die richtige Antwort und destruktive Interferenz
für die falsche Antwort.
Also sehen wir die falsche Antwort nicht, wir sehen nur die richtige Antwort.
Lass mich jetzt etwas mehr über das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen sagen, um es aus einem
etwas anderen Blickwinkel zu betrachten.
Zunächst wollen wir
diese sehr einfache Formel beobachten, bei der b und c beliebige binäre Werte sind.
Kurz gesagt, das XORen eines Bits b mit dem Wert 1 ist dasselbe wie das Anwenden eines NOT gates oder einer X-Operation auf b,
und natürlich bewirkt das XORen
eines Bits b mit dem Wert 0 nichts damit, was dasselbe ist wie das Anwenden der
Identitätsoperation darauf.
Und wir können die Identitätsoperation als X hoch 0 ausdrücken.
Also wenn wir ein Uf gate auf zwei qubits im Standard-Basiszustand
ket b Tensor ket a anwenden,
erhalten wir dieses Ergebnis, einfach durch die Definition des Uf gates.
und mit der Formel können wir diesen Zustand alternativ so schreiben, wie du es hier siehst.
Diese Formel gilt für alle Wahlen von b, also gilt sie durch Linearität
für einen beliebigen Zustand SI
an Stelle von ket b.
Und insbesondere, wenn wir möchten, können wir SI als den Minus-Zustand wählen.
Und hier ist der Schlüssel dafür, warum das phase kickback
Phänomen auftritt.
Es liegt daran, dass die x-Operation,
angewendet auf den Minus-Zustand, uns negativ 1 mal den Minus-Zustand ergibt.
In mathematischer Sprache sagen wir, dass der Minus-Zustand
ein Eigenvektor der x-Operation ist, mit dem Eigenwert negativ 1.
Eigenvektoren und Eigenwerte
sind sowohl in der linearen Algebra als auch
in der Quanteninformation von entscheidender Bedeutung, und wir werden noch viel
mehr über sie zu sagen haben
im weiteren Verlauf der Reihe.
Aber im Moment brauchen wir
nur diese einfache Formel.
Und damit können wir
unseren Zustandsvektor vereinfachen.
Und genau das ist im Wesentlichen das phase kickback
Phänomen als Formel ausgedrückt.
Es funktioniert, weil der Minus-Zustand
ein Eigenvektor der NOT-Operation ist und
den Eigenwert negativ eins hat.
Wir werden das in Lektion 7 auf eine
ziemlich bedeutende Weise verallgemeinern, wenn wir uns dem phase
estimation Verfahren zuwenden, das Shors
Faktorisierungsalgorithmus antreibt.
Wir können diese Formel in Aktion bei der Analyse von Deutschs
Algorithmus wie folgt sehen.
Vor dem query gate ist unser Zustand das Tensorprodukt des Minus- und Plus-Zustands.
Wir wenden dann das query gate an, und das Ausschreiben des Plus-Zustands
ergibt diesen Zustand.
Wir wenden jetzt die phase kickback Formel an, um diesen Ausdruck zu erhalten, und dann geht die Analyse
wie zuvor weiter.
Es ist dasselbe wie zuvor, aber hier legen wir
einfach den Fokus auf das phase kickback, damit wir es erkennen können
und auch darauf vorbereitet sind,
wenn es erneut auftaucht.
Als nächstes wenden wir uns dem
Deutsch-Jozsa Algorithmus zu, der eine Erweiterung
von Deutschs Algorithmus ist und tatsächlich ein paar
verschiedene query-Probleme löst.
Der Vorteil, den
Deutschs Algorithmus gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen
bietet, ist ziemlich bescheiden: eine Anfrage gegenüber zwei.
Der Deutsch-Jozsa Algorithmus vergrößert diesen Vorteil etwas, und ich werde erklären, was ich damit meine,
wenn wir dazu kommen.
Der Deutsch-Jozsa Algorithmus kann als eine natürliche und direkte Möglichkeit betrachtet werden, Deutschs Algorithmus zu erweitern
von Funktionen von einem Bit auf ein Bit zu Funktionen von n Bits auf ein Bit, oder mit anderen Worten, Funktionen dieser Form.
Als quantum circuit sieht der Deutsch-Jozsa
Algorithmus so aus, und ich werde das
als Deutsch-Jozsa circuit bezeichnen
nur um eine kleine
Unterscheidung zwischen diesem circuit und dem Deutsch-Jozsa Algorithmus selbst zu ziehen, weil es auch einen
klassischen Nachverarbeitungsschritt gibt.
Die Idee ist, dass wir, wenn wir
diesen circuit ausführen und dann messen, einen n-Bit-String y erhalten
der uns etwas
über die Funktion f verrät.
An diesem Punkt habe ich übrigens noch nicht gesagt,
was das query-Problem ist, das wir hoffen könnten
mit diesem circuit zu lösen – das kommt sehr bald.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass
wir durch das Ausführen dieses circuits einige Informationen über f gewinnen, die uns potenziell helfen können,
query-Probleme zu lösen
bei denen f die Eingabe ist. Und wie ich eben sagte, können wir diesen circuit tatsächlich verwenden
um ein paar verschiedene
query-Probleme zu lösen.
Schauen wir uns zunächst
das query-Problem an, das als Deutsch-Jozsa Problem bekannt ist und das das Problem ist, das
der Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
ursprünglich lösen sollte.
Das Deutsch-Jozsa Problem ist eine Verallgemeinerung von Deutschs Problem, bei dem das Ziel darin besteht, festzustellen, ob eine gegebene Funktion
konstant oder ausgeglichen ist.
Beachte, dass dies nicht die natürliche Weise ist, das Paritätsproblem
auf Funktionen dieser Form zu verallgemeinern.
Hier berechnen wir nicht die Parität, die Aufgabe besteht darin, 0 auszugeben, wenn
die Funktion f konstant ist
und 1, wenn die Funktion f ausgeglichen ist.
Das Erste, was bei
diesem Problem auffällt, ist, dass wenn n, die Anzahl der Eingabebits der
Funktion f, mindestens 2 beträgt,
es Funktionen gibt, die weder konstant noch ausgeglichen sind.
Hier ist zum Beispiel eine
Funktion von 2 Bits auf 1 Bit, die weder konstant noch ausgeglichen ist.
Sie ist nicht konstant, weil beide binären Werte
unter den Ausgaben erscheinen, und sie ist nicht ausgeglichen,
weil die beiden Ausgabewerte
mit unterschiedlichen Häufigkeiten auftreten. 0 erscheint dreimal
und 1 erscheint nur einmal.
Um ausgeglichen zu sein,
müssen die Ausgaben 0 und 1 genau
gleich oft vorkommen.
Die Tatsache, dass es Funktionen gibt, die weder konstant noch ausgeglichen sind, wenn n mindestens 2 ist, ist jedoch in Ordnung – wir werden solche
Funktionen einfach betrachten
als "egal"-Eingaben. Mit anderen Worten ist
das ein Versprechen-Problem.
Und hier ist eine genaue
Formulierung des Problems.
Es wird uns versprochen, dass die Eingabefunktion f entweder konstant oder ausgeglichen ist, und das Ziel ist herauszufinden,
welches von beidem zutrifft.
Und wir sind nicht dafür verantwortlich, was passiert, wenn die Eingabe
das Versprechen nicht erfüllt.
Der Deutsch-Jozsa Algorithmus,
der dieses Problem löst, besteht darin, zuerst den Deutsch-Jozsa circuit auszuführen und dann 0 auszugeben
wenn der String, den wir
aus den Messungen erhalten, der Nullstring ist,
und andernfalls 1 auszugeben.
Anders ausgedrückt: Wir geben das ODER der
Bits aus, die wir messen.
Um den Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus zu analysieren, ist es hilfreich,
zunächst kurz über Hadamard gates nachzudenken.
Wir können die Hadamard-Operation
natürlich als Matrix beschreiben, aber auch
durch ihre Wirkung
auf Standardbasiszustände,
wie du hier siehst.
Diese beiden Gleichungen lassen sich
zu einer einzigen Gleichung zusammenfassen, die beschreibt, wie eine
Hadamard-Operation funktioniert, wenn a einer der
beiden Binärwerte ist,
und wir können noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und das Ergebnis
als eine Summe wie diese ausdrücken.
Mit dieser Formel können wir eine Formel aufstellen, die beschreibt, wie eine Schicht
von Hadamard gates funktioniert, wobei wir ein Hadamard
gate auf jeden von n qubits anwenden.
Hier beschreiben wir diese
Wirkung auf Standardbasiszustände.
Zur Klarstellung der Notation: Wenn wir h tensor n so schreiben, wobei der tensor-n-Teil ein Hochzeichen ist,
meinen wir damit das n-fache
Tensorprodukt von H mit sich selbst, oder anders gesagt, n Kopien
von h alle zusammen tensoriert.
Wir wenden diese Operation
auf einen Standardbasiszustand an, und hier folge ich der
Konvention, die Qiskit verwendet,
um binäre Strings zu indizieren, einfach weil es ein guter Moment
ist, diese Konvention einzuführen.
Also ist x0 ein Bit, x1 ist ein Bit,
und so weiter mit insgesamt n Bits, und die Bits sind geordnet,
wie du hier auf dem Bildschirm siehst.
Du kannst diese Art der Bit-Indizierung als
Entsprechung ihrer Wertigkeit betrachten, wenn wir Strings als
ganze Zahlen auffassen,
zum Beispiel in Binärdarstellung.
Wenn wir ein Hadamard gate
auf jeden dieser qubits anwenden, können wir das Ergebnis alternativ als das n-fache Tensorprodukt ausdrücken.
eines Hadamard gates, das auf jeden qubit angewendet wird, und dann können wir unsere Formel auf jeden der Tensorfaktoren anwenden.
Und hier verwenden wir die
Namen y und minus 1 bis y1 anstelle von b in der Formel,
das sind also Binärwerte. Und wir achten darauf, jedes Mal, wenn wir die Formel verwenden, einen neuen Namen zu benutzen.
Wenn wir dann alles unter Verwendung der Multilinearität
von Tensorprodukten auseinanderfalten, erhalten wir den Ausdruck,
den du hier siehst.
Und zur Klarstellung: Die n Summen werden
zu einer einzigen Summe zusammengefasst, aber wir summieren immer noch
über alle möglichen Werte
der einzelnen Binärwerte.
Jetzt wollen wir die Dinge bereinigen, damit wir etwas weiter gehen können.
Der nächste Schritt besteht darin,
eine neue Operation auf Strings einzuführen, das binäre Skalarprodukt.
Das ist eine Operation auf binären Strings gleicher Länge.
Das binäre Skalarprodukt zweier Strings x und y
gleicher Länge ist das exklusive ODER oder die Parität
der Produkte der einzelnen Bits.
Man könnte auch sagen, es ist das XOR des logischen UND der einzelnen Bits, denn das UND ist
dasselbe wie das Produkt
für Binärwerte. Noch eine andere Beschreibung:
Es ist 1 oder 0,
je nachdem, ob
die Summe der Produkte der einzelnen Bits ungerade oder gerade ist.
Es ähnelt sehr einem inneren Produkt, wenn wir Strings
als Vektoren von Binärwerten betrachten, aber berechnet Modulo-2,
oder anders gesagt, wir nehmen den Rest nach der Division durch 2.
Es ist aber kein wirkliches inneres Produkt, daher verdient es einen anderen Namen.
Im vorliegenden Fall können wir das binäre
Skalarprodukt verwenden, um unsere Formel für die Wirkung einer Schicht von Hadamard gates
auf Standardbasiszustände prägnanter zu gestalten, und hier ist sie.
Wir nutzen die Tatsache, dass
weil diese Summe hier im
Exponenten von minus 1 erscheint,
nur entscheidend ist, ob
sie gerade oder ungerade ist, aber ansonsten ist es im Wesentlichen nur eine kompakte
Version unserer Formel.
Übrigens ist das binäre
Skalarprodukt in dem Sinne symmetrisch, dass x dot
y und y dot x gleich sind,
wir also die Reihenfolge frei tauschen können,
wann immer das nützlich ist.
Und jetzt, da wir diese Formel haben, wird es ziemlich einfach sein, den
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit zu analysieren.
Wir beginnen mit n qubits im Zustand 0 und dem untersten qubit im Zustand 1, und wir führen Hadamard
gates auf all ihnen aus.
Das ist also der Zustand der
n + 1 qubits, den wir erhalten.
Wir behandeln den
untersten qubit separat, weil das praktisch ist.
Und wieder werden wir das Phase-Kickback-Phänomen beobachten.
Wir können diesen Ausdruck erhalten,
indem wir unsere Formel verwenden, wobei wir den
Nullstring für x und x für y einsetzen,
und beachten, dass das binäre
Skalarprodukt des Nullstrings mit einem beliebigen String 0 ist.
Aber wir können das auch direkt schlussfolgern. Wir bilden das Tensor-
produkt von n Plus-Zuständen, und das erhalten wir,
tensoriert mit dem Minus-Zustand. Dann wird das UF gate angewendet, und hier passiert das
Phase-Kickback-Phänomen.
Der Wert f von x wird
für jedes x in der Summe auf den Minus-Zustand XOR-verknüpft.
Also wird f von x in die Phase verschoben.
Wir wenden jetzt eine weitere
Schicht von Hadamard gates nur auf die oberen n qubits an, und diesmal brauchen wir
wirklich die Formel.
Und wenn wir sie anwenden und nur ein bisschen
vereinfachen, erhalten wir diesen Zustand hier.
Das ist also unser Endzustand kurz
vor den Messungen.
Der Zustand sieht etwas kompliziert aus, und es ist schwierig, ihn zu vereinfachen, weil wir eigentlich nichts
über die Funktion f wissen.
Aber denk daran, dass wir
nur wissen müssen, ob die Messungen
alle das Ergebnis 0 liefern oder nicht,
denn das bestimmt, was unsere Antwort auf das Problem ist.
Wenn wir sehen, dass jedes
Messergebnis 0 ist, schließen wir daraus, dass die Funktion konstant ist.
Und wenn eines der
Messergebnisse 1 ist, schließen wir daraus, dass die Funktion balanciert ist.
Berechnen wir also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, den Alles-Null-String
aus den Messungen zu erhalten.
Und das erweist sich als das einzige Ergebnis, das tatsächlich einfach zu berechnen ist, weil das binäre Skalarprodukt
des Alles-Null-Strings
mit jedem String null ist. Wenn wir unseren Vektor betrachten und
darüber nachdenken, was passiert, wenn y der Alles-Null-String ist,
erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck hier
für die Wahrscheinlichkeit, den Alles-Null-String
aus den Messungen zu erhalten.
Und wenn wir die beiden möglichen Fälle berücksichtigen, in denen f konstant und f balanciert ist, sehen wir, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
den Alles-Null-String zu erhalten, 1 beträgt
in dem Fall, dass f konstant ist, und null, wenn f balanciert ist.
Wenn f konstant ist, ist die Summe entweder 2 hoch
n oder minus 2 hoch n, und wenn man durch 2 hoch n dividiert
und den absoluten
Betrag quadriert, ergibt sich 1.
Und wenn f balanciert ist, ist die Summe gleich 0.
Das liegt daran, dass wir
plus 1 und minus 1 gleich oft erhalten,
sodass sie sich alle aufheben.
Das war's also. Der Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus
löst das Deutsch-Jozsa-Problem mit einer einzigen Abfrage,
und es gibt keinen Fehler. Vorausgesetzt, die Operationen
werden alle perfekt ausgeführt, ist er jedes Mal korrekt.
Wie vergleicht sich das also mit dem,
was wir klassisch tun können?
Nun, wenn wir auf einem
deterministischen Algorithmus bestehen, der die Antwort
jedes Mal richtig liefert, dann brauchen wir im schlimmsten Fall
2 hoch n minus 1 plus 1 Abfragen, und das liegt daran, dass wir
die Funktion abfragen müssen
bei mehr als der Hälfte ihrer Eingaben, um sicher über die Lösung zu sein.
Selbst wenn wir die Funktion bei 2 hoch n minus 1
verschiedenen Eingabe-Strings abfragen, ist es möglich, dass wir
denselben Ausgabewert sehen
jedes einzelne Mal, und das könnte daran liegen,
dass die Funktion konstant ist, oder es könnte sein, dass sie tatsächlich balanciert ist
und wir nur unglaublich unglücklich waren und jedes Mal
denselben Ausgabewert gesehen haben.
Das ist also ein enormer Vorteil
von Quantum gegenüber Klassisch: eine einzige Abfrage gegenüber
exponentiell vielen Abfragen.
Wenn wir jedoch einen
probabilistischen Abfrage-Algorithmus verwenden und eine kleine Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit akzeptieren,
dann brauchen wir tatsächlich nur ein paar Abfragen.
Wenn wir insbesondere
zufällig k Strings wählen und die Funktion
auf diesen zufälligen Strings auswerten,
dann können wir die richtige Antwort wahrscheinlich herausfinden.
Konkret antworten wir 0 oder konstant, wenn wir jedes Mal denselben Funktionswert
erhalten, und 1 oder balanciert,
wenn wir zwei
verschiedene Funktionswerte sehen.
Wenn wir das tun, liegen wir immer richtig, wenn
die Funktion konstant ist, denn natürlich sehen wir in diesem Fall immer denselben
Ausgabewert.
Und wenn f balanciert ist, werden wir sehr wahrscheinlich
zwei verschiedene Ausgabewerte sehen.
Die Chance, dass wir in diesem Fall nicht
beide Ausgabewerte sehen, ist dieselbe wie die Chance, eine Münze k Mal zu werfen
und jedes Mal dasselbe
Ergebnis zu erhalten.
Wenn wir also zum Beispiel
k gleich 11 setzen, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine falsche Antwort zu erhalten, kleiner als ein Zehntel Prozent.
Besonders wenn wir bedenken, dass Quantencomputer in der Realität niemals perfekt sein werden, erhalten wir hier keinen wirklich
großen Vorteil,
aber wir machen Fortschritte, und wir haben einen quantifizierbaren Vorteil von Quantum gegenüber Klassisch, der über Deutschs Algorithmus hinausgeht.
Wir können den Deutsch-Jozsa-circuit auch verwenden, um ein anderes Abfrageproblem zu lösen, das als Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem bekannt ist.
Hier ist eine Beschreibung dieses Problems. Die Eingabe ist eine Funktion
von n Bits auf 1 Bit, genau wie beim Deutsch-Jozsa-Problem,
und wieder ist es ein Promise-Problem.
Diesmal ist das Versprechen, dass es einen n-Bit-String s gibt, für den die Funktion f
so funktioniert, wie du es hier siehst,
wobei die Ausgabe durch das
binäre Skalarprodukt der Eingabe mit diesem String s gegeben ist,
und das Ziel ist einfach,
den String s zu finden. Wir können uns also vorstellen, dass der
String s in gewissem Sinne verborgen ist,
aber wir können etwas darüber erfahren,
indem wir Abfragen an f stellen, und unser Ziel ist es, diesen
verborgenen String zu finden.
Um das klarzustellen: Die meisten Funktionen
werden dieses Versprechen nicht erfüllen, aber wie üblich interessieren uns nur die
Eingabefunktionen, die das tun.
Es stellt sich heraus, dass der Deutsch-Jozsa circuit dieses Problem
direkt und ohne Weiteres löst.
Wenn wir ihn für eine
Funktion wie diese hier ausführen, die das
Versprechen für einen String s erfüllt, enthüllen die Messungen den String s
ohne dass eine Nachbearbeitung erforderlich ist.
Schauen wir uns also an, wie das funktioniert.
Wir haben den Deutsch-Jozsa circuit bereits analysiert,
also können wir direkt
zum Ende springen.
Hier ist der Ausdruck, den wir
zuvor für den Zustand unmittelbar vor den Messungen hatten, und dieser Ausdruck war
für jede Funktion f gültig.
Wenn wir jetzt einsetzen,
was uns über die Funktion f versprochen wird, und vereinfachen,
erhalten wir den Minus-Zustand
für das untere qubit, tensoriert mit cat s für die oberen n qubits.
Und so erhalten wir s beim Messen.
Es gibt einige Arbeit, um die Vereinfachungen durchzuführen,
die ich hier gezeigt habe, und ich werde das in diesem Video nicht durchgehen,
aber im Lehrbuchinhalt zu dieser Serie gibt es dazu mehr Details, die du über den Link in der Videobeschreibung finden kannst,
oder versuch es einfach selbst
als Übung.
Was wir also festgestellt haben, ist, dass
der Deutsch-Jozsa circuit das Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem
mit einer einzigen Abfrage löst.
Es ist nicht allzu schwer zu zeigen,
dass jeder klassische Algorithmus, egal ob deterministisch
oder probabilistisch, mindestens n Abfragen benötigt,
um das Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem zu lösen, aus dem einfachen Grund, dass wir n Bits an
Information benötigen, um s zu rekonstruieren,
und jede Abfrage uns höchstens
1 Bit an Information liefert.
Damit haben wir einen weiteren Vorteil von Quanten- gegenüber klassischen
Abfragealgorithmen: eine Abfrage für Quantenalgorithmen,
n Abfragen für klassische Algorithmen.
Es lohnt sich, kurz über die
Nomenklatur zu sprechen, die im Kontext dieses Problems verwendet wird, und ein wenig über die Geschichte.
Manchmal wird der Algorithmus, den ich gerade beschrieben habe, als Bernstein-Vazirani-Algorithmus bezeichnet, aber es ist eigentlich nur der
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit,
und das wurde
tatsächlich sehr klar in Bernstein und Vazirani's Arbeit festgestellt.
Es ist also etwas seltsam, dass er
Bernstein-Vazirani-Algorithmus genannt wird, weil er im Grunde dasselbe ist wie der Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus
minus der Nachbearbeitung. Bernstein und Vazirani sind jedoch
einen Schritt weiter gegangen.
Sie haben eine rekursive
Version dieses Problems definiert, bei der man im Grunde
Instanzen des Bernstein-Vazirani-Problems lösen muss,
um neue Instanzen des Problems freizuschalten, die in einem
komplizierten baumartigen Muster angeordnet sind.
Es ist ein sehr konstruiertes Problem, aber der Punkt ist, dass sie durch
die Definition eines Problems auf diese Weise effektiv
die Eins-gegen-n-Abfragetrennung zwischen Quanten- und klassischen Algorithmen ausdehnen konnten.
Und was sie erhielten, ist
das allererste bekannte Beispiel eines sogenannten superpolynomiellen Vorteils von Quanten- gegenüber probabilistischen Algorithmen.
Diese rekursive Version des
Bernstein-Vazirani-Problems erwies sich auch viel später
in der Berechnungskomplexitätstheorie aus anderen Gründen als sehr interessant.
Jedenfalls ist der Punkt, dass
Bernstein und Vazirani sicherlich Anerkennung für ihre wichtigen Beiträge verdienen,
aber es macht wirklich keinen
Sinn, das als Bernstein-Vazirani-Algorithmus zu bezeichnen – es ist im Grunde nur der
Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus.
Im letzten Teil der Lektion schauen wir uns einen
weiteren Quantenabfragealgorithmus an, der als Simons Algorithmus bekannt ist.
Du wirst eine klare Ähnlichkeit
zwischen diesem Algorithmus und dem Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus sehen, aber er ist anders, und was noch wichtiger ist:
Er enthüllt einen viel stärkeren Vorteil von Quanten- gegenüber klassischen
Abfragealgorithmen.
Konkret gibt er uns einen
beweisbaren exponentiellen Vorteil von Quanten- gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen, sogar probabilistischen.
Das Problem, das er löst, ist etwas künstlich, und es ist schwer, sich eine Situation vorzustellen, in der das Lösen dieses Problems nützlich wäre,
aber es hat direkt
Peter Shor's Entdeckung eines Quantenalgorithmus
für die ganzzahlige Faktorisierung inspiriert,
und das unterstützt sehr stark
diese Idee des Abfragemodells als Petrischale, in der Quantenalgorithmen
entwickelt werden können.
Beginnen wir mit dem Abfrageproblem, das Simons Algorithmus löst, das, wie du vielleicht erraten hast,
Simons Problem genannt wird.
Hier ist eine Formulierung des Problems, und wir müssen sie aufschlüsseln, um zu verstehen, worum es geht.
Das Erste, was
auffällt, ist, dass die Eingabefunktion f diesmal n
Bit-Strings auf m Bit-Strings abbildet,
wobei m eine positive ganze Zahl ist, die im Allgemeinen nicht gleich eins ist.
Es ist ein Promise-Problem. Und wie beim Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem beinhaltet das Versprechen einen String s, den wir als versteckten String betrachten können,
und wie beim
Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem ist das Ziel,
diesen versteckten String s auszugeben.
Das Versprechen ist diesmal
jedoch komplizierter, also schlüsseln wir es auf und
verstehen, was es besagt.
Zunächst lesen wir es einfach. Es sagt, dass es einen String s der Länge n gibt,
sodass eine bestimmte "wenn"
und "nur wenn"-Bedingung für alle Wahlen von n Bit-Strings x und y wahr ist.
Konkret muss
es so sein, dass f von x gleich f von y ist, genau dann wenn eine von
zwei Möglichkeiten gilt.
Die erste Möglichkeit ist, dass x gleich y ist, und die zweite Möglichkeit ist, dass wir durch das bitweise eXklusive ODER von x
mit dem verborgenen String s Y erhalten.
Das ist ein ziemlich striktes Versprechen in dem Sinne, dass die meisten
Funktionen es nicht erfüllen.
Nur sehr spezielle Funktionen
erfüllen diese Bedingung.
Um das Versprechen und damit das Problem selbst besser zu verstehen, betrachten wir zwei Hauptfälle.
Der erste Fall ist, dass s
der Null-String ist.
In diesem Fall können wir die „wenn"
und „nur wenn"-Aussage im Versprechen vereinfachen, da das bitweise
eXklusive ODER eines beliebigen Strings x
mit dem Null-String
einfach der String x ist.
Die Bedingung vereinfacht sich also
zu: f von x ist gleich f von y genau dann, wenn x gleich y ist.
Und das ist nur eine andere Art zu sagen, dass f eine eins-zu-eins-Funktion ist.
Mit anderen Worten: der String f von x muss eindeutig
für jeden möglichen String x sein.
Wenn f also eine eins-zu-eins-Funktion ist, ist das Versprechen tatsächlich erfüllt, konkret für s als
dem Null-String,
und in diesem Fall ist das
die korrekte Ausgabe.
Der zweite Fall ist, dass s
nicht der Null-String ist, und das impliziert, dass die Funktion f zwei-zu-eins sein muss.
Für jeden Eingabe-String x gibt es also genau einen weiteren String, den f auf denselben
String abbildet wie x,
und außerdem muss der andere String
der String sein, den wir erhalten, indem wir das bitweise
eXklusive ODER von x mit s nehmen.
Eine andere Art, das zu sagen,
ist, dass jeder n-Bit-String x einen Partner hat, und dieser Partner ist der String, den wir erhalten,
indem wir das bitweise eXklusive ODER mit s nehmen.
Zwei Partner müssen immer
denselben Ausgabe-String liefern, wenn wir sie in f einsetzen, und kein anderer String darf
diesen Ausgabe-String liefern.
Die Strings, die Partner erzeugen, sind daher notwendigerweise verschieden.
Hier ist ein Beispiel für eine solche Funktion, beschrieben durch ihre Wertetabelle.
Das ist also eine Funktion
von 3 Bits auf 5 Bits.
Wenn wir diese Wertetabelle
eine Weile betrachten, stellen wir fest, dass das Versprechen
für den String 011 erfüllt ist.
000 und 011 sind Partner. Das XOR von einem der beiden
mit s ergibt den anderen,
und sie haben denselben Ausgabewert, der in diesem speziellen Fall 10011 ist, und kein anderer String erzeugt
diesen Ausgabe-String.
001 und 010 sind Partner, weil das XOR von einem der beiden
mit s den anderen ergibt, und sie denselben Ausgabewert erzeugen,
der wiederum von keinem
anderen String erzeugt wird.
Und die Situation ist
ähnlich für 100 und 111 sowie 101 und 110.
Wenn also die Eingabe für das
Problem diese Funktion ist, ist die korrekte Antwort der String 011.
Wie ich bereits sagte, erfüllen die meisten Funktionen dieses Versprechen nicht, es ist eine sehr spezifische Bedingung.
Es sei auch darauf hingewiesen, dass,
wenn das Versprechen erfüllt ist, es nur für einen einzigen String s erfüllt sein kann.
Es gibt also immer nur eine
richtige Antwort auf dieses Problem.
Das ist also Simons Problem. Wie ich sagte, ist es schwer, sich eine praktische Situation vorzustellen, in der du dieses Problem lösen möchtest,
aber darum geht es nicht. Der Punkt ist herauszufinden, worin Quantencomputer gut sind, und es stellt sich heraus, dass sie klassischen Algorithmen weit überlegen sind,
wenn es darum geht, dieses
spezielle Problem zu lösen.
Schauen wir uns nun
Simons Algorithmus an, der Simons Problem löst.
Der Algorithmus besteht darin,
den circuit, den du hier siehst, mehrmals auszuführen, gefolgt von einem klassischen
Nachverarbeitungsschritt,
und wir werden später genauer erklären, was „mehrmals"
bedeutet.
Der circuit sieht dem Deutsch-Jozsa circuit sehr ähnlich, diesmal weil die Funktion
f n Bits auf m Bits abbildet,
ist das query gate anders. Anstatt nur eines einzigen
qubit unten haben wir jetzt m qubits unten
und n oben wie zuvor.
Ein wesentlicher Unterschied ist, dass wir
keinen Minus-Zustand oder mehrere Minus-Zustände unten einrichten.
Diese unteren qubits sind alle
auf den 0-Zustand initialisiert, und diese Zustände gehen direkt
in das query gate.
Es wird also kein Phase-Kickback in diesem Algorithmus verwendet, das ist einfach nicht die Funktionsweise dieses Algorithmus.
Abgesehen von den Unterschieden,
die ich gerade erwähnt habe, sieht er dem Deutsch-Jozsa circuit sehr ähnlich.
Wir wenden eine Schicht von Hadamard gates an, dann wenden wir einmal ein query gate an, und dann wenden wir eine weitere
Schicht von Hadamard gates an,
gefolgt von Standardbasis-Messungen der oberen n qubits.
Die Idee ist, dass wir jedes Mal, wenn wir
diesen circuit ausführen und messen, einen String y erhalten, der uns etwas
über den verborgenen String s verrät,
bei Simons Problem. Und indem wir den circuit
mehrmals unabhängig voneinander ausführen, haben wir genug
statistische Evidenz über s gesammelt,
um ihn mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
herausfinden zu können.
Lass uns nun den quantum
circuit für Simons Algorithmus analysieren, um zu sehen, was er tut.
Der Zustand nach der ersten
Schicht von Hadamard gates sieht so aus, ähnlich wie das, was wir beim
Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus hatten.
Außer dass diesmal die unteren m qubits alle im Zustand 0 sind
und nicht in Minus-Zuständen.
Nachdem das query gate ausgeführt wurde, sehen wir, dass der Wert f von x auf die
unteren oder linksten m qubits geschrieben wurde,
und das liegt daran, dass f von x mit dem Alles-Null-String XOR-verknüpft wurde.
Also findet auch in diesem Algorithmus kein Phase-Kickback statt.
Anschließend führen wir die zweite
Schicht von Hadamard gates aus.
Und mit der gleichen Formel wie zuvor für die Wirkung einer
Schicht von Hadamard gates auf einen Standardbasisvektor,
cat x in diesem Fall,
wie es in der ursprünglichen Formel war, erhalten wir diesen Zustand hier, bei dem die Wirkung der Hadamard gates
deutlicher gemacht wurde. Aber wenn wir möchten, können wir den Zustand
auch in einer kompakteren Form schreiben, wie wir es hier haben.
An diesem Punkt messen wir die oberen n qubits, um einen n-Bit-String y zu erhalten, und wir müssen nur herausfinden,
wie die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind
für die verschiedenen Strings. Und das wird uns helfen zu verstehen,
welche Informationen wir aus diesem String y über den String s erhalten,
der in der Funktion f versteckt ist.
Wir werden etwas mehr
Platz brauchen, und das circuit-Diagramm brauchen wir wirklich nicht mehr,
also entfernen wir es und schaffen uns etwas
mehr Platz für die Analyse.
Hier ist der Zustand kurz
vor den Messungen, bei denen es sich um Standardbasismessungen der oberen oder rechtesten n qubits handelt.
Die Messung
entspricht also dem zweiten cat.
Bezeichnen wir mit p von y die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Messungen uns den String y für jedes mögliche y liefern.
Und wenn wir die Regeln aus Lektion 2 befolgen, ergibt sich, dass jede dieser Wahrscheinlichkeiten das quadrierte euklidische Betrag des Vektors ist, der mit dem Standardbasisvektor tensoriert wird,
der dem y in
unserem Quantenzustandsvektor entspricht.
Das ergibt diesen Ausdruck hier.
Um diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten besser handhaben zu können,
müssen wir einige Notationen verwenden, mit denen du vielleicht schon
vertraut bist,
weil sie in der Mathematik sehr verbreitet sind.
Erstens, wenn wir uns auf den
Wertebereich der Funktion f beziehen, meinen wir einfach die Menge aller Strings, die aus dieser Funktion herauskommen können.
Es ist also die Menge aller f von x, über alle möglichen
Eingabe-Strings x.
Zweitens werden wir diese Notation verwenden, die du hier siehst, um die Menge aller Eingabe-Strings x zu bezeichnen,
die f auf einen gegebenen String z abbildet, für welche Wahl von
z wir auch betrachten möchten.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie die
Inverse der Funktion f, aber es ist nicht wirklich die Inverse, weil f nicht notwendigerweise invertierbar ist.
Wir sehen auch, dass wir auf der linken Seite als Argument eine Menge haben,
und in diesem Fall ist es die Menge, die
nur einen einzigen String z enthält,
und das ist der Hinweis, den wir brauchen, um zu erkennen, dass wir nicht über
die Inverse der Funktion f sprechen – das nennt sich das Urbild (pre-image).
Das Urbild kann
allgemeiner für jede als Argument gegebene Menge definiert werden, nicht nur für die Menge mit
einem einzigen Element,
aber das ist alles, was wir brauchen werden. Es ist nicht die schönste
Notation der Welt, weil man sie leicht mit
der Inversen verwechseln kann,
aber sie ist klar genug
und weit verbreitet, also bleiben wir dabei.
Und wenn wir jetzt diese Notation verwenden, können wir den Vektor umschreiben, von dem wir das quadrierte euklidische Betrag nehmen,
um die Wahrscheinlichkeit für das
Messen jedes Strings y zu erhalten.
Wir machen das, weil wir sehen müssen,
welche Koeffizienten für jeden einzelnen Standardbasisvektor vorliegen, was aus
diesem Ausdruck hier nicht klar ist,
weil es im Allgemeinen mehrere
Auswahlmöglichkeiten von x geben kann, die uns denselben String f von x liefern.
Im Wesentlichen teilen wir nur
die Summe über x auf, indem wir zunächst über alle
z im Wertebereich von f summieren,
und dann innerhalb dieser Summe über alle x im Urbild von z summieren, oder um genauer zu sein,
das Urbild der Menge,
die den String z enthält.
Das erlaubt uns, f von x durch z innerhalb des cat hier zu ersetzen.
Und die Summe über alle verschiedenen Strings
x, die f auf jedes z abbildet, werden in den
Koeffizienten für jedes cat gesammelt.
Wir sortieren im Grunde Strings in Behälter, summieren über die Behälter und summieren dann über
die Strings in jedem Behälter,
aber das ist äquivalent dazu, einfach
über alle Strings zu summieren.
Wir erhalten also einen Ausdruck, der äquivalent zu dem ist,
mit dem wir begonnen haben,
und jetzt können wir das
quadrierte euklidische Betrag berechnen.
Es ist einfach die Summe der Quadrate der Absolutwerte
der Koeffizienten, und so erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck hier
für unsere Wahrscheinlichkeiten.
Nimm dir natürlich
die Zeit, das zu überprüfen, wenn du das möchtest – es braucht Zeit, sich an all das
zu gewöhnen und diese Berechnungen
durchführen zu können, und je mehr du übst, desto einfacher wird es.
Bisher haben wir die Vorgabe in
Simons Problem überhaupt noch nicht verwendet.
Unsere Analyse dieser Wahrscheinlichkeiten funktioniert tatsächlich für jede Funktion f, aber jetzt ist es Zeit, über Simons
Problem im Speziellen nachzudenken.
Wir werden die Dinge in dieselben zwei Fälle
aufteilen, die wir zuvor hatten.
Der erste Fall ist, dass s
der Null-String ist, und der zweite Fall ist, dass
s nicht der Null-String ist.
Im ersten Fall, dass
s der Null-String ist, sind die Dinge ziemlich einfach.
In diesem Fall, wie wir zuvor gesehen haben, ist f eine eins-zu-eins Funktion, also gibt es genau einen String x,
der auf jeden der
Strings z im Wertebereich von f abgebildet wird.
Das macht den Absolutwert zum Quadrat der Summe über diese Strings gleich 1, weil es nur einen
einzigen Term in der Summe gibt,
er ist entweder plus 1 oder minus 1, aber es spielt keine Rolle welcher, weil wir den
Absolutwert zum Quadrat nehmen, und so erhalten wir eins.
Es gibt 2 hoch n
Elemente im Wertebereich von f, und das wissen wir, weil f eins-zu-eins ist, also gibt es einen String im
Wertebereich für jeden Eingabe-String.
Und wenn wir den gesamten Ausdruck auswerten, stellen wir fest, dass jeder String y mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit
eins durch zwei hoch n auftritt.
Mit anderen Worten liefern uns die
Messungen einen gleichmäßig zufällig gewählten String y.
Das scheint vielleicht nicht besonders nützlich zu sein, aber wir werden tatsächlich in der Lage sein,
dieses Verhalten von dem Verhalten zu unterscheiden, das wir im Fall erhalten,
dass s nicht der Null-String ist, und wir werden gleich sehen, wie das funktioniert.
Fürs Erste stellen wir jedoch einfach fest, dass wenn
f die Bedingung in Simons Problem im Fall erfüllt, dass s der Null-String ist,
das Ergebnis der Messungen ein gleichmäßig zufälliger String ist.
Kommen wir nun zum zweiten Fall, bei dem die Bedingung
für einen String s erfüllt ist, der nicht der Null-String ist.
In diesem Fall, wie wir zuvor besprochen haben, hat jeder String z im Wertebereich von f genau zwei Strings, die auf ihn abgebildet werden,
weil jeder String einen Partner hat, und jedes Paar von Partnern
auf einen eindeutigen String abgebildet wird, und insbesondere ist der Partner jedes Strings
der String, den wir durch XOR-Verknüpfung mit s erhalten.
Wenn wir also einen beliebigen String
z im Wertebereich von f auswählen und einem der
Strings, die f auf z abbildet, den Namen w geben,
dann ist das XOR von w mit s der
andere String, der auf z abgebildet wird.
Betrachten wir nur den einen Term in unserer Summe, der dem jeweiligen String z im Wertebereich entspricht, den wir im Sinn haben,
sehen wir, dass wir ihn
expliziter schreiben können, wie wir es hier rechts haben.
Wir haben zwei Strings im Urbild von z, w und w XOR-verknüpft mit s.
Wir können die Summe also so
schreiben, wie du es auf dem Bildschirm siehst, und jetzt können wir einen Faktor von
minus 1 hoch w.y ausklammern.
Dieser Faktor wird
entweder plus 1 oder minus 1 sein, also fällt er weg, wenn wir
den Absolutwert nehmen,
und was uns bleibt, ist
dieser Ausdruck hier rechts.
Die Details sind hier nicht vollständig gezeigt, und es ist nicht unbedingt
offensichtlich, dass es auf diese Weise funktioniert, aber du kannst überprüfen, dass diese
beiden Ausdrücke gleich sind,
indem du zur Definition
des binären Skalarprodukts zurückgehst und darüber nachdenkst, was passiert, wenn diese Dinge im
Exponenten von minus 1 stehen,
ähnlich wie bei dem, was wir für das
Bernstein-Vazirani-Problem hatten.
Schließlich können wir diesen
Ausdruck in zwei Fälle aufteilen.
Er ist 4, wenn das binäre Skalarprodukt
von s und y gleich 0 ist, und er ist 0, wenn das binäre
Skalarprodukt von s und y gleich 1 ist.
Beachte insbesondere, dass hier
überhaupt keine Abhängigkeit von w oder z besteht, es hängt nur von s und y ab.
Der Grund, warum das so ist,
liegt an der sehr spezifischen und besonderen Natur der Bedingung.
Im Wesentlichen ist das der Grund, warum die Bedingung auf diese Weise formuliert wurde, damit alles so aufgeht.
Nochmals, jeder String hat einen Partner, den wir durch XOR-Verknüpfung mit
diesem einen verborgenen String s erhalten,
und das ist es, was all das möglich macht.
Wir können nun zum Ausdruck für die Wahrscheinlichkeiten zurückgehen
und die Werte einsetzen.
Wenn s nicht der Null-String ist, gibt es 2 hoch n minus 1
Elemente im Wertebereich von f,
was der Hälfte der
Anzahl der Eingabe-Strings entspricht, und das Einsetzen der
soeben berechneten Werte ergibt diese Formel hier rechts.
Diesmal ist y also kein
vollständig zufälliger String, sondern y ist gleichmäßig über genau die Hälfte der n-Bit-Strings verteilt,
und zwar gleichmäßig über diejenigen Strings, deren binäres Skalarprodukt
mit s gleich 0 ist.
Jetzt, da wir wissen, wie der circuit
für Simons Algorithmus funktioniert und insbesondere, wie die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen Messergebnisse sind,
bleibt zu erklären, wie uns das hilft, Simons Problem zu lösen.
Zusammenfassend was wir gerade gelernt haben: Wenn die Funktion f die Bedingung in Simons Problem erfüllt,
wenn der verborgene String s
der Null-String ist, erhalten wir aus den Messungen einen vollständig zufälligen String,
bei dem jeder n-Bit-String
y gleich wahrscheinlich ist.
Wenn andererseits die Funktion f die Bedingung für einen anderen String s erfüllt, einen der nicht gleich
dem Null-String ist,
dann erhalten wir einen zufälligen String y, dessen binäres Skalarprodukt
mit s gleich 0 ist, und unter all diesen Strings
ist jedes y gleich wahrscheinlich.
Aber wir werden nie einen String y erhalten, dessen binäres Skalarprodukt
gleich 1 mit s ist.
Die Frage ist: „Reichen diese Informationen aus,
um s zu bestimmen?" Und die Antwort, wie ich
bereits angedeutet habe, lautet: ja,
vorausgesetzt, dass wir den
circuit oft genug ausführen.
Konkret nehmen wir an,
dass wir den circuit k-mal ausführen, wobei K gleich n plus r ist,
wobei r eine Zahl ist, die die
Wahrscheinlichkeit steuert, mit der wir s wiederherstellen.
Nehmen wir zum Beispiel an: Wenn
wir r gleich 10 wählen, sind wir mit einer
Wahrscheinlichkeit von mehr als 99,9 % erfolgreich,
r muss also gar nicht so groß sein.
Im Allgemeinen ist die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit geringer als die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
eine faire Münze r-mal zu werfen und jedes Mal Kopf zu erhalten.
Wenn also 99,9 % nicht ausreichen,
nimm r gleich 20, und die Fehlerchance ist
kleiner als eins zu einer Million,
oder wähle das r,
mit dem du dich wohlfühlst. Du kannst keine korrekte Lösung garantieren, aber du kannst die
Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit vernachlässigbar klein machen
für alle praktischen Zwecke.
Hier benennen wir diese
Strings y1 bis yk, wobei wir Superskripte verwenden, um diese Strings zu benennen,
damit wir Subskripte verwenden können, um auf die einzelnen
Bits dieser Strings zu verweisen.
Das sind also keine Exponenten
oder Ähnliches – das sind nur die Namen, die wir diesen k Strings geben.
Jeder hat die Länge n, weil wir sie durch
Ausführen des circuits für Simons Algorithmus erhalten haben.
Wir können also die
einzelnen Bits dieser k Strings aufschreiben, wie du es hier siehst.
Was wir jetzt tun, ist eine Matrix m zu erstellen, wobei jeder Eintrag dieser Matrix ein Bit ist, und wir erhalten diese Bits aus den Strings,
die wir gerade gemessen haben, genau wie hier gezeigt.
Diese Matrix hat also k Zeilen und n Spalten, und ihre Einträge sind alle binäre Werte.
Nun kennen wir s nicht. Das ist es, was wir zu finden versuchen, aber stell dir einen
Moment vor, dass wir s kennen würden,
und wir haben einen Spaltenvektor
aus den Bits von s gebildet, genau wie hier gezeigt.
Wenn wir diesen Vektor mit m multiplizieren und dann das Ergebnis modulo-2 nehmen, oder anders gesagt,
wir ersetzen die Addition
durch das exklusive ODER, dann erhalten wir zwangsläufig
den Nullvektor.
Das liegt daran, dass jeder der
Einträge in diesem resultierenden Vektor nichts anderes ist als das
binäre Skalarprodukt von s
mit einer der Zeilen von m.
Wenn s zufällig der Null-String ist, erhalten wir immer den Nullvektor aus dem binären Skalarprodukt.
Und wenn s nicht der Null-String ist, erhalten wir dies aus dem, was wir
über die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die Strings y1 bis yk wissen.
Insbesondere ist das
binäre Skalarprodukt mit s immer null für alle diese Strings.
Einfach ausgedrückt: Dieser Vektor,
der aus den Bits von s gebildet wird, liegt immer im Nullraum der Matrix m,
vorausgesetzt, dass wir alle
unsere Arithmetik modulo-2 durchführen, aber natürlich kennen wir s nicht,
wir versuchen s zu finden.
Aber was wir tun können, ist den
Nullraum dieser Matrix m zu berechnen, wieder modulo-2.
Konkret können wir das mithilfe der Technik der
Gaußschen Elimination tun, die das Verfahren ist, das oft gelehrt wird
in einführenden Kursen zur linearen Algebra.
Es funktioniert einwandfrei, wenn wir unsere gesamte Arithmetik modulo-2 durchführen, und es lässt sich
mit einem Computer sehr effizient erledigen.
Und wenn wir den Nullraum von m berechnen, angesichts der spezifischen Art, wie diese k Strings
zufällig gewählt wurden,
werden wir s mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als
1 minus 2 hoch minus r wiederherstellen können.
Genauer gesagt werden wir mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als
1 minus 2 hoch minus r sehen, dass der Nullraum
den Nullvektor enthält,
wie es für jede Matrix immer der Fall ist, sowie den Vektor, der s entspricht, egal ob es der Nullvektor ist oder nicht.
Und am wichtigsten: Keine anderen Vektoren werden
im Nullraum erscheinen.
Das ist eigentlich nicht so schwer zu beweisen, obwohl ich es hier nicht im Detail durchgehen werde.
Die Idee ist, dass wenn wir
einen anderen String haben, der nicht der Nullvektor
und nicht s ist, dann wird jeder der zufälligen
Strings y1 bis yk
ihn grundsätzlich mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem Halb
aus dem Nullraum herausbefördern.
Nach k Durchläufen ist es also
sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass er überlebt, und tatsächlich wird keiner der
Strings, die nicht dazugehören,
wahrscheinlich überleben. Und ein sehr einfaches Ergebnis
aus der Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie, bekannt als die Union Bound, kann
verwendet werden, um das zu belegen.
Ich habe hier nicht alle
Details erklärt, aber hoffentlich verstehst du die Idee, dass wir durch Berechnung des Nullraums modulo-2 dieser Matrix m
sehr wahrscheinlich s wiederherstellen werden, und das ist, wie Simons Algorithmus
Simons Problem löst.
Es bleibt nur noch eine Sache
zu Simons Problem zu sagen, und die betrifft die klassische
Schwierigkeit dieses Problems,
das heißt, wie viele Anfragen braucht ein klassischer Anfragealgorithmus, um Simons Problem zu lösen?
Die Antwort lautet: im Allgemeinen viele.
Es gibt verschiedene präzise
Aussagen, die man über die klassische
Schwierigkeit dieses Problems machen kann, und hier ist nur eine davon.
Wenn wir einen beliebigen probabilistischen
Abfragealgorithmus haben und dieser Algorithmus weniger als 2 hoch n durch 2
minus 1, minus 1 Abfragen macht,
also eine Anzahl von Abfragen,
die exponentiell in n ist, dann wird dieser Algorithmus daran scheitern,
Simons Problem zu lösen,
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mindestens einem Halb.
Manchmal kann es sehr schwierig sein,
Unmöglichkeitsergebnisse wie dieses zu beweisen, aber dieses ist nicht allzu schwer zu beweisen
durch eine elementare
probabilistische Analyse.
Das werde ich in dieser Videolektion nicht tun, sondern mich stattdessen nur
auf die Intuition dahinter konzentrieren.
Wir versuchen, den verborgenen String s zu finden, aber solange wir die Funktion nicht auf zwei Strings abfragen, die denselben
Ausgabewert haben,
erhalten wir sehr begrenzte
Informationen über s.
Im Grunde lernen wir nur,
dass der verborgene String s nicht das exklusive ODER von zwei beliebigen verschiedenen
Strings ist, die wir abgefragt haben,
Und wenn wir die Funktion bei weniger als dieser Anzahl von Abfragen abfragen, gibt es immer noch viele Möglichkeiten für s,
die noch nicht ausgeschlossen wurden.
Das ist kein formaler Beweis,
aber das ist die grundlegende Idee.
Zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen, dass Simons Algorithmus uns einen auffälligen Vorteil von Quanten- gegenüber klassischen
Algorithmen im Abfragemodell bietet.
Insbesondere löst Simons
Algorithmus Simons Problem mit einer Anzahl von Abfragen, die linear in der Anzahl der Eingabe-
bits n unserer Funktion ist,
während jeder klassische Algorithmus,
selbst wenn er probabilistisch ist, eine Anzahl von
Abfragen benötigt, die exponentiell in n ist,
um Simons Problem mit einer vernünftigen Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit zu lösen.
Es stimmt, dass Simons Problem ein etwas künstliches Problem ist, das vermutlich niemand
wirklich lösen möchte,
aber das ist zweitrangig. Manchmal müssen Ideen entwickelt werden, bevor sie in die Praxis umgesetzt werden.
Und tatsächlich hat Peter Shor klar erklärt, dass es Simons Algorithmus war, der seinen heute
berühmten Quantenalgorithmus inspiriert hat
zur ganzzahligen Faktorisierung, den wir in ein paar Lektionen sehen werden.
Und damit ist Lektion 5 zu Ende.
In dieser Lektion haben wir einen Blick auf das
Abfragemodell der Berechnung geworfen und eine Reihe von Beispielen gesehen
von Quantenalgorithmen,
die Vorteile gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen
in diesem Modell aufzeigen.
Es ist tatsächlich noch viel mehr
über das Abfragemodell und Quantenalgorithmen für andere Probleme bekannt, die
ich nicht besprochen habe.
Wenn du dieses
Modell also interessant findest, gibt es noch einiges
mehr darüber zu lernen.
Unser nächster Schritt wird sein, uns
vom Abfragemodell zu entfernen und hin zu einem Berechnungsmodell,
das repräsentativer ist
für die Art von Problemen, die wir in der Praxis zu lösen hoffen.
Ich hoffe, du wirst mich in Lektion 6 begleiten, in der wir uns hauptsächlich darauf konzentrieren werden,
eine Grundlage für das Studium von Quantenalgorithmen zu legen.
Und von dort aus werden wir zu einigen
spezifischen Quantenalgorithmen übergehen, darunter Shors Algorithmus
zur ganzzahligen Faktorisierung
in den folgenden Lektionen. Auf Wiedersehen bis dahin!